with the big dog in the Chess Club Tony
rich our people were slim these days so
not as big a dog as he used to be in
shrinking slowly but surely but
certainly still with a lot of influence
welcome to the show Tony the grand
chester has been spectacular so far
norway chess was incredible this first
four rounds off the sink filled cup plus
this fifth round has been very exciting
is it what you'd hoped when you were
sitting in your office and planning this
stage this tour no it's much more than I
could have hoped for honestly you know
the the idea of the sink filled cup when
that came about seemed like a dream come
true it seemed like something they could
never happen and then sure enough man
it's going to be here in st. Louis and
we had the best to in the world play the
best to Americans then the next year we
grew to six and now this year we thought
well how are we going to continue to
make this event and impactful and and
one of the biggest events on the chest
calendar each year and the way we found
to do that was by creating the grand
chest or we recognize that there are
organizers out there that really
exemplify what a chess event should be
the gold standard you know if you will
and Norway chest one in chess classic
and seemed filled cup in our eyes were
some of the very best so you know being
able to travel to Norway earlier this
year heading to London later this year
and watch these players as they battle
it out it's really less of a sprint now
and it's more of a marathon they're
competing over the entire year against
each other face to face head-to-head
heads up ultimately to win the coveted
grand chest or prize yeah it's been
incredible and i gotta say i'm jealous
you went to Norway I didn't so did ya
sir but that's different question we
talked to the other boss lady joy break
that's right but the grand chest or has
plans for the future this is not the end
of it your plans to grow tell us about
that that's right in fact the 2016 grand
chest or calendar will be announced
tomorrow so make sure you tune in to
grand chest or calm to find out the
dates for our 2016 events I can tell you
that Norway chess the London chess
classic and the sink filled Cup will be
on the calendars and keep your eyes
peeled there may be more can you give us
a little hint as to what those more
might be absolutely like I said we
always look for the very best chess
events around the world so whenever you
think of the big tournaments the
national top level competitions some of
those names might pop up you still
haven't said anything sure have that's
my political answer for the Clancy yeah
you should be running for office you
know a lot of people don't realize that
there are chest fans who work in chess
as well you know of course you have
somebody like myself who is basically a
retired player but loves the game and
loves to do my job but you're a chess
fan as well a pretty good player
yourself expert rated player that's what
is it like to have the demigods or it
guess it's the gods of chess walking
into your door walking into your club I
remember when you first introduce me to
this club you toward it it was not a
club it what it was just a nothing
inside it was rubble in fact and you had
a vision for what this might become and
now years later you're rubbing shoulders
with the world's best players it's funny
as kind of a teaser leading into the
sink filled Cup this year I wrote an
article where I talked about the first
time I met a grandmaster and it was
grand master Sergey Kudrin we brought
him to st. louis he came to the we are
just pawns chess club that meta dough
barnes and noble and and it was a that
was a dream come true for me was the
first time i had met a grandmaster shook
his hand played a simon stim and it was
everything I could have hoped for right
and so I was I was hooked I remember
spending time sitting in the fraternity
in college and watching the World
Championship match between kramnik and
Casper oh that you so abele did
commentary for with with yasser you know
you read about these guys in the
magazines or you see pictures of them
online you see the games that they
create and it's beautiful these are
really masterpieces that are creating
over the board and have the chance to
shake their hand and look in their eye
and say why didn't you play Queen d2 and
you know that's that's great for a pots
are like me and then they explain while
you're dropping a piece you know yeah
don't try to suggest moves to these guys
still have a long ways to go before I'm
a grandmaster oh you're definitely a
grandmaster organizer and certainly a
gentleman thanks so much for all the
work that you do for chess it's a
pleasure thanks Tony rich one of the
good guys in chess doing a lot of work
in helping to transform the face of
chess in America and around the world